Tran Ukrainians kill Ukrainians I  believe this is as close to a civil war  as you can get so what's going on now  and you there are some people in without  any identification and a uniform black  uniform some say this is the right  sector there certainly many many facts  from from the right sector there were  reports about a couple of hundreds or  more of mercenaries including the rumors  which was spread in the German media  about the Graystone Academy from a  Blackwater American private military do  you believe that they're American  mercenary I send a message through our  ambassador to Washington asking to to  respond to these assertions from the  German media because the if you think  our American refers to this effect war  spread even before and John Kerry  rejected them now they are popped up  again and we would like to see whether  this is true or not